a rare glimpse of rhinos drink them
because poachers could rob you of this
magnificent creature it's a black rhino
one of only a few thousand left in the
world because of poaching every one of
them now critically endangered and this
one is particularly precious they've
named her goose and she was found merely
dead after being shot through the foot
by hunters she's female which means she
could breed and that puts her in an
ultra special category there was the
bottom harvest oh my goodness no
literally every bone is broken in that
foot she had no soul and this pink part
is where there was a piece of bone
protruding so they've gone to
extraordinary lengths to save her she's
been darted with tranquilizer her horns
already been shaved to deter more
poachers it takes a whole team of people
to maneuver her into position
[Music]
this bespoke cast is what's saving her
foot and her life and this is what the
Kruger Park Rangers and vets have been
doing every few weeks for goose for the
past nine months and they've drafted in
an expert
Johan Marais spends his life saving
endangered animals she's sort of really
critical to us you know the future is in
these these sorts of animals is these
reading females elephant hide is used to
cover the damaged foot it's then sealed
with fiberglass and two student vets are
monitoring gooses breathing they want to
limit her anesthetic to an hour so they
must work quickly me this is something
that I'll probably carry me for the rest
of my life for them all this is a labor
of love you know things like this has
never be portent for me as a
veterinarian to actually find out what
is possible in a one or two ton animal
she's been under anaesthetic mail for
just over an hour they're going to bring
her round any minute now and then
they'll go through this whole procedure
again in about a month's time goose has
survived because of the Kruger Park
Rangers refusal to let her die it's been
a very long road to get to this point
huge numbers of people and hours and
hours of groundbreaking care but the
Rangers hope shall eventually give birth
to more black rhino and that will help
guarantee the survival of her species
Alex Crawford Sky News in Kruger Park
South Africa